I have to start this week's direct
message with a trigger warning that's
right so take a moment get a design
comfy and move carefully to your safe
space because we've got to talk I'll
actually wait for just a bit all right I
think that did it now that you've been
trigger warned yeah let's talk about
free speech it feels like it's on the
ropes these days right well we've been
talking a lot about it here in the
context of how the regressive stifled
debate by calling everyone racist sexist
homophobic or the rest this very concept
tolerance for intolerance has been
taking root at college campuses across
the country for quite some time now
there are two completely separate
situations unfolding right this very
moment one is on the campus of Yale
where some students were upset that a
professor wrote a letter defending the
right to wear offensive Halloween
costumes the letter in part explained
that you can either ignore the costume
altogether or you can engage in the
person wearing the costume telling them
why you find it offensive apparently
this wasn't enough for some of the
students culminating a video that has
now gone viral in which a student
screams at the Dean quote it's not about
creating an intellectual space it's
about creating a home here the other
situation is at the University of
Missouri where students were fed up with
a series of racially motivated instances
they felt weren't being properly dealt
with by the administration the students
demanded the resignation of the school
president which he submitted after the
mostly black football team got involved
a video on campus has also gone viral
showing a young journalist trying to
cover the protests but being screamed at
and bullied by a group of students
ironically these students are trying to
silence someone who was only there to
cover the very protests that they wanted
attention for for one of the oldest and
largest journalism schools in America it
seems that mu has gotten something very
wrong about free speech of course these
two instances are not isolated in
America nor in other parts of the
Western world colleges and universities
are the very places you're supposed to
go to engage in the battle of ideas to
new ways of thinking and to challenge
your preconceived notions
yet somehow colleges are the very place
that have become hostile to all of these
concepts now shouting down speakers you
don't agree with demanding professors be
fired for contrarian views and denying
the media free and unfettered access
have found their home in these safe
spaces of course this all ties in
perfectly with everything we've been
talking about on this show the
regressive left by calling everyone
racists and bigots and homophobes and
the rest have ushered in a generation of
people who are so sure in their beliefs
and so dismissive of their opponents
ideals that they have no reason to stand
up for free speech anymore if your
opponent is a racist or a bigot then why
even engage with them you've got the
moral high ground so just shout them
down or call them names until they give
up these are the tactics the regressive
have used successfully in so many areas
and now we're seeing the fruits of their
labor I want to be very clear here
nothing I'm saying is dismissive of the
actual issues these college students are
dealing with there is no doubt we have
racial problems in this country we have
equality problems we have wealth
disparity problems and the list goes on
and on but these problems won't go away
if we don't talk about them they won't
magically resolve themselves if we only
talk to people we agree with actually
they'll only get much worse this is the
inherent flaw of identity politics that
the regressives love so much when you
Whittle us all down just to race
religion nationality sexuality or
whatever else there is there's very
little left to unite us I'd much rather
look at people based on their ideas and
their beliefs those are the principles
that unite us across the divide that the
regressive left has been digging I've
been saying for a while now that two
things can be true at once in this case
it can be true that these students have
legitimate grievances and at the same
time it can be true that free speech
shouldn't be sacrificed on the altar of
political correctness we should be more
worried about the government taking away
our free speech rather than us taking it
away from ourselves some say the road to
hell is paved with good intentions
some say the ends justify the means some
just want to shut you up and that's when
you have to speak the loudest
you